i don't see myself yet there i am
hello everyone
i'm back
no one's showed up yet here so i'm
waiting for a few of you
um
sunday again i'm trying to do more of
these live streams so i can i really
enjoy speaking to some of you well i
enjoy speaking to all of you really
um and so i'm trying to do more of these
livestream now some people are showing
up hello people
hi everyone how are you
very nice to see everyone
i hope most of you have seen the latest
video i'm not expecting you to have
watched it yet of course but
just uh
well less than an hour ago i posted the
new video which is on astrology
in the early islamic world as part of a
collaboration with angela puka
from the channel angela symposium he's a
wonderful scholar and expert on
all things occult and esotericism
shamanism and also things like astrology
like i also say in the video so
really really an honor to collaborate
with people like angela we did a
collaboration last year too about sufism
actually um and so it's really great to
be able to work together again as i've
said in other
videos before i really
this is one of the
the best things about what we're doing
here on youtube i think is creating this
uh community of collaborators who can
work together and and bring you this
kind of content i i really feel
privileged to be uh able to do that with
all of these talented people is the
volume low again
because it's it's it's uh basically
on full blast right now i think
yep
not much else i can do so you'll have to
you'll have to uh
you'll have to make do with this for now
i think volume is fine okay good
um khadijah asks if i check my twitter
messages i actually don't i check
messages from people
um that i already
follow or that we follow each other but
i don't
really keep up with
messages from people
that i that you know the message
requests essentially
for various reasons
if you want to reach out to me you can
send me an email or contact me in some
other way
okay
so as you can tell from the title too
this is actually pretty uh important of
course uh i forgot to mention this is
that just a few days ago um we reached
300 000 subscribers so again i've you
know i can't keep repeating the same
things again but i am truly
just in awe and
i
i'm really honored that so many of you
seem to be interested in my videos so uh
thank you all so much thank you to
everyone who subscribes and everyone who
watches everyone who i collaborate with
this this is
such a wonderful experience to be able
to
do this like do these videos and do
things that i'm passionate about and i
also reach an audience to which i can
you know with which i can talk about
these things it's really the most
wonderful thing i see that zevi is in
the chat nice to see you again and zevi
was so nice sent me a message
congratulating me the other day when i
reached 300 000.
xavi is just such an amazing guy
so again if you're not subscribed to
seekers of unity xavi's channel then go
do that right now
he is
really
he's able to
straddle that line between really
passionate and engaged and also like
rigorous uh academically as well he is
amazing at what he does i really
appreciate sevi on his channel
um
so again thank you all so much for uh
for getting us to this point 300 000
that's a lot of people
that's a lot that's like bigger than
some
major cities here in sweden
so that's really really strange
but i i i truly appreciate it
i am free
to
[Music]
answer some questions
i guess
and again
i know that a lot of your questions will
be regarding what what you know video
suggestions and requests for the future
uh
and as i said last time the answer to
most of those questions will be yes
and i won't be able to to answer all of
those questions right now but but i'll
try to answer as many as possible
did you like the video today on
astrology it's a it's a fascinating
topic and i was able to really only able
to scratch the very surface of that
tradition
and had to focus really on that
particularly the early islamic period
with figures like el kindy and abomasher
there are other others of course from
that period but i i think that those two
are some of the most important at least
in terms of theory
alkene these ideas about the stellar
rays and abomash's writings which have
become so important to later
um astrology all across the world well
not maybe all across the world but at
least in in the
middle east and europe and and the
western world as angela talks about in
her video about astrology in western
esotericism
uh azram
talks about uh translating videos to
other languages i've definitely been
thinking about doing that
at least having someone help me out in
translating the the like the subtitles
to have subtitles in other languages
that would be really great because i
know
there is a huge
audience that don't speak english and
that would be really helpful
i just haven't been able to
get that project going but yes that's
something i would really like to do to
be able to reach as many people as
possible
want more videos about islam trishit
does well
iran luck
has islam tends to pop up a lot on this
channel
um some people are confused why there's
so much islam on this channel
and that is because that's what i know
best it's the thing that i've focused on
and where i have my expertise or most of
my expertise
because that's what i
focused on during my studies during both
my bachelor's and master thesis i
studied islam and particularly i've
studied sufism so
i know more about those topics which
makes it
i guess easier to make those videos not
not that it's easy per se but i i have
the literature i know the literature
that i will need and i have a lot of
knowledge on that topic already so that
you know
and also i'm just really interested in
that because i have that knowledge
already
you know the more knowledge you have
about something the more interested you
are in it i would say most of the time
at least so
that's the reason why there's so much
islam is that that's the thing that i
know best
but
with that said i tried as much as
possible to
keep the channel varied and i really
my aim is to talk about as broad of a
spectrum of religious traditions as
possible
pluto let's do a field trip to algeria i
would love to go to algeria at some
point
really like all of those like algeria
would love to go to morocco i was going
to go to morocco actually a few weeks
back that was the plan
originally but because of the pandemic
that wasn't possible
but i would love to go to algeria for
like personal reasons because it seems
beautiful and and wonderful in a lot of
these places but also
for of course the sake of this channel
to to gather
material and experiences to to
well for later uh content essentially
lord tennyson's pipe
says that my arabic pronunciation is
stellar thank you very much
and he asked would you ever make videos
on buddhism or the debates between
buddhist and vedanta scholars
uh yes
i i addressed this question in the last
live stream as well i've been reading up
on a lot of buddhism lately
that's one of those religions that i
have had the least amount of knowledge
at least when it comes to the sort of
the big major religions of the world
um
i've had the basic knowledge and the
sort of overview of the different
schools and ideas but it's my knowledge
on buddhism has been
and to some degree still is somewhat
limited and that's why i haven't covered
it yet but i have been really
studying and researching more about
eastern
buddhism so like mahayana buddhism in
particular and the tiantai school
of buddhism which has this fascinating
idea about the three
truths so mahayana buddhism
and the philosophy of nagarjuna for
example has this idea of the two truths
the two truth theory the tiantai
buddhists have the three truth theory
which is so like buddhism again
um
which a lot of people might not expect
but buddhism is one of like the most
deep and complex and like developed
philosophical traditions
in the world probably and
also to compare buddhist philosophy and
ideas to vedanta would be really
fascinating too a lot of people have
already done that i think but yes i
would love to talk about that
john commander what's your name
my name is
philip is my name
tahir or taher asks do you practice
sufism are you a disciple of any certain
superior i'm not initiated in any sufi
order or any lineage of sufi
any lineage of sufism
although i have
spent a lot of time with sufis and in
sufi gatherings and with super
practitioners and
participated in that kind of thing
for you know when i did field work for
my master's thesis for example
um so i have i've been in those
environments but i'm not initiated
in a sufi order as such
curry aficionado
great name asked by the why do even
atheistic ideologies like communism
assume the shape and form of religion i
don't know maybe maybe just maybe that's
just uh part of like the way that humans
organized themselves
something about the sociology of social
organization or something i don't know
um i would assume that
humans have a tendency to to
create similar structures around a
certain ideology or or
an identity
because as i've said
i tend to be
sociologically inclined when it comes to
religion like their kaimen kind of
perspective that religion is primarily
about identity and
belonging and so on not that that's like
exclusive religion is about but like on
a
societal level
i tend to be in line with those kinds of
ideas
osman zahed or zahid asks how do you
deal with existential crisis it depends
well i'm not a psychologist so if if
you're having trouble
with that kind of
if we have an existential crisis or you
have anxiety or anything then you should
speak to a professional and not listen
to some random youtuber but
i think it depends on what is troubling
you i guess
one thing that really has really helped
me with various problems mentally and
then psychologically over the years
is the classic thing of of exposure i
don't know if that's what it's called in
english but basically like phasing
facing your your fears like really if
you're afraid of something the best
antidote is to just
uh
just walk up to that fear and and
just stare it in the face and that's
the first step to
to getting rid of that kind of thing
suspicious mind is it snowing in sweden
not currently i think there's a storm
here
but i haven't seen any snow i haven't
left the my apartment today because of
the storm so i really
i don't know i might take a trip to the
to the convenience store after i
finished the stream but no it's there is
snow on the on the ground but it isn't
snowing it was snowing the other week
do you think sufism follows quran yeah i
mean the whole tradition of sufism is
essentially based on the same
sources that
any other islamic
tradition is based on which is the quran
and the hadith literature and the
the law of schools and all this
definitely at least they consider
themselves to be following the quran
they read the same quran
and they see their tradition as being
completely in line with that and has a
correct understanding of the quran it's
not that sufis at least most sufis that
they
see themselves as
coming from some other tradition and
then
pretending to be muslims you know it's
it's really they understand themselves
as being the most
the deepest and most uh
authentic version of islam
and from a sort of academic and neutral
perspective
the way we have we look at religious
identification and religious affiliation
is that if someone calls themselves a
muslim then they're they're muslim we
have to
um
operate from that perspective because we
don't get involved in like theological
discussions about who's a heretic or
who's reading the quran correctly that's
completely
irrelevant to
the academic study of religions
and from that perspective sufis are
definitely muslims and they definitely
follow the quran
but i think the majority of them at
least
per the fact that they consider
themselves to be doing that
would make a great video have you
started his life and ideas at all yes
ibn hassan is fascinating ibn hazm was
an under lucian
well polymath he was a theologian and
philosopher and uh jurists and all kinds
of things who lived around the turn of
the first like the last millenniums
around the year thousand
and he fascinatingly belongs to the
zahidi school of law which is mostly has
mostly died out it's not part of the
four
main law schools and the zahidi school
is
characterized
by
a strict literalism
so they read the scriptures very
literally and they they don't take much
well i'm not an expert on zahidi
methodology but they essentially take
the scriptures and they
try to add as little as possible to to
what it says
um and what's so fascinating about ibn
hassam is that you would think that that
like from a modern perspective
you would think that that would make him
like really fundamentalist or really
strict or rigid but it's actually a lot
of cases the opposite ibn has him
through his literalism actually has
pretty
what we would call liberal ideas like i
think
i don't quote me on this now because i i
can't remember the source but i'm pretty
sure that he for example
um
considered it forbidden to force women
to cover their faces because to him
there was no basis for that in any of
the scriptures so evan has him is really
fascinating that he he
goes against a lot of assumptions about
what we would think about a literalist
kind of approach to religion and i would
definitely want to
make a video about him in the future
joseph ali yes he was also well i
wouldn't say one of the few scholars but
yes he's one of those examples of
scholars who
does consider music to be completely
allowed in islam too so ibn has a really
really fascinating figure
also probably a huge influence on ibn
arabi and his methodology for reading
the quran which is also contrary to what
many people might assume ibn arabi is
actually quite a literalist reader of
the quran
of course he thinks that every quranic
verse has like deeper layers and a bunch
of
different
deeper interpretations and and and so on
but
in terms of the outer layer and the
meaning of the text he's very much a
literalist which
a lot of people don't expect and it
probably gets a lot of those uh ideas
and methodologies from ibn hassam who
after all is from the same region of
spain only like a century before
i saw some questions for example what is
the difference between salafism and
wahhabism that's a very good question
and i
want to cover that in a future video
because that's a whole thing
um
in very very general terms wahhabism
which is a term that others apply to
this group that we call wahhabis they
don't like that term themselves they
actually see that as quite controversial
quite um offensive a lot of them
they call themselves the muahidoon i
think the monotheists
and like a lot of groups call themselves
the muahidun so it would be wouldn't be
that useful to use that term either
but so the wahhabis essentially is a
group that originates with the teachings
of a scholar
in saudi arabia in the 18th century
called muhammad ibn abdul wahab
who was
influenced by people like him taimiya
for example and was very much a kind of
well a fundamentalist
um not necessarily you know without
putting any
value in that word just like factually
like objectively he was a fundamentalist
in the sense that he saw himself as
bringing islam back to some kind of pure
version and wanted to do away with all
kinds of innovations like shiism and
and
and sufism and things like that
and wahhabism is also the ideology and
theology and so on that
the kingdom saudi arabia has adopted to
a large degree because the saud family
who rules
saudi arabia today was close
they worked together essentially with
abu wahab in the 18th century now
salafism you could say is a is a
movement that
emerged now salafist themselves will of
course say that they are just the
original version of islam of the
companions of the prophet but in terms
of their religious movement they
originate primarily i think in the 20th
century i would say in certain reform
movements of trying to modernize islam
and to do away with what they saw as
superstition like sufism and things like
that and instead again this notion of
going back to the pure version of islam
practiced by the
salaf assalah
the pious predecessors and this reform
movement is associated with people like
muhammad abdul
and his student rashid riddha
and
is very important for the establishment
of salafism and so it's a complicated
thing but
wahhabis so some i've heard people say
that all wahhabis are salafis but not
all salafis are wahabis
um
because the salafi approach is
essentially the same in the love ways as
the wahhabi approach but the wahhabis
have a certain
theology and
legal methodology that not all salafis
follow
it's complicated i'll leave that
discussion in the future to a future
video essentially
what's my favorite david bowie album i
really
uh i don't i really like uh low
i think is really cool
it's just so
dark especially the second half of that
album
i also really like his last album too a
black star i thought was uh
really wonderful
and just like the whole thing about like
he he knowing that he was going to die
and like yeah it's a really also i like
dark stuff apparently because that's a
really dark album too because of that
whole story surrounding it but i think
it's really beautiful
music
um
so let me scroll up a bit see if i can
find
again curry aficionado wants me to
comment on what i think happens after we
die
and the answer is i don't know
and anyone that says differently
i think
one should be careful with
if they say they know for sure like we
can have ideas and
and
things we believe but no one knows for
sure that's my perspective on it
michael muller did you study music
formally no actually i'm mostly
self-taught actually i've played music
in various
constellations and ways over the years
and
learned
like i don't know much theory for
example and that's probably as a result
of not studying
music formally but i've sort of learned
theory
gradually over the years as i've been
playing music with people who have been
a lot more talented than me
um i appreciate that you like the music
that i
that i make for those of you who don't
know i've started posting more on my
other channel which is simply called
philippe hall which is my name
um and that channel is going to be
primarily dedicated to music and so i
will do
music
i put my own music on there but i also
do videos that are somewhat similar to
the videos on here
i just did one on an instrument called
the duduk which is a wind instrument
from the
central asian anatolian region
and i will be making videos about
various topics related to music so a
video coming up is going to be about the
indian musician tansen
who was a musician in the court of the
emperor akbar
and so i'll be making videos on that
channel that i don't think really fits
on let's talk religion because there's
no clear connection to religion in that
sense
um so if you're interested in
that kind of content about music then
go check out that other channel too it's
uh
it's down at the bottom of of this
channel's main page are some links to
that
which religion do you think best i'm
assuming you mean which religion i think
is the best one and i don't
i don't i can't i don't have an answer
to that question because i don't have a
religion that i think is the best
i think it's hard
to study religions as broadly as
as we do in the way that we do
and to see the historical developments
of all these religions and then to have
an opinion that one of those
has exclusive rights to being true it
just doesn't
add up to me so i
there's no religion i consider to be the
best one
yes bilal i'm going to talk about the hd
order definitely
there is an exciting
video coming up in which the ch2 order
will be an important part and that is a
video that i'm doing about sufi music
and it's probably going to be one of the
most ambitious videos that i've ever
done the script is long
it's almost as long if not as long
actually as my video on adabi
something about 24 pages or something um
so i'm that's one of the next videos i'm
going to do and the chisholm is very
important for that and
because that's going to be a long video
probably extend to like around an hour
long if i'm if i were to guess um you're
going to have to
um give me some extra time to to work on
that one so there might be silence for
like two three weeks
and we'll see how long that that takes
hello andrew relindy for breakfast is in
the chat thank you so much andrew
um
and thank you for being a great uh
inspiration
for creating wonderful content and for
giving me the honor of collaborating
with you as well on the gnosticism video
thank you so much
and again
if i'm assuming a lot of you know about
andrew's channel religion for breakfast
and if you don't then what are you even
doing here you should go right now and
subscribe and check out his videos
uh
one of the best channels about religion
on all of youtube and a huge inspiration
to
the stuff that i do as well
yes andrew i agree the the kind of
channels that we're doing uh
like you and me and then justin and
angela and and all these people uh seem
to
gain an increasing audience and that's
really exciting to see because that
i think that's a really good sign that
one that people are interested in and
like trustworthy and actually good
content about religion
and that if it reaches a wider audience
then religious literacy
um will increase as well and that's
really what we're after
at the end of the day
any videos about lord shiva
definitely
i'm
really excited to be well i'm looking
forward to making a video or cellular
videos about the shy guy traditions and
kashmir shaggism for example
and i've
started working on some of those scripts
or one of those script
so you can look forward to that also in
the future
pluto is a planet do you meditate i do
but i've really been really bad at
keeping up that practice lately
i think it's a wonderful way to well for
various reasons
uh
aegon hindu and buddhist is it true that
ancient germanic peoples believed in
monotheism one god in many forms i read
on wikipedia that they were monotheistic
similar to the concept of brahman in
hinduism i don't know that much about
the religions of ancient germanic
peoples so i can't really comment on
that
i wouldn't be
surprised if there was a kind of concept
of a singular divine
being or principle that's tends to be
pretty common in
what we call polytheistic religions uh
in like the aztec religion we have this
concept of teot
which is a kind of
oneness
i don't know enough about that to speak
on it at any length either but
uh the same is true for brahman like you
said for
um
many
digitologists will also argue that
ancient egypt also had that kind of idea
that there are many gods but there is a
singular one god or divine principle
of which these other deities are just
manifestations
other scholars disagree about that
though so
it's it's a debate that still
isn't settled so to say
but in terms of the germanic peoples i
really don't know which maybe i should
because that's a lot closer to where i
live geographically
but i haven't gotten there yet
hopefully in the future
i.a are religions man-made
from the perspective from like a
scholarly academic perspective that we
approach religions as
human phenomena
and religious in terms of organized or
institutionalized religions as
human
sociological
creations essentially yes
there are
there are other
um well there are actual scholars with
phds in the in the chat so if if i say
something that
is inaccurate then they can probably
correct me too
let's see i saw a question
ahmed hasn't have you got hate comments
for creating these contents i mean i
think it's inevitable that some people
get upset over a topic that is as
sensitive and
can be as controversial as religion so
yeah i've definitely had people
be upset and
write that kind of comments i tend to
not like i don't
it doesn't bother me because i expected
that when i started the channel but
there's never been anything like serious
except maybe once
but um
yeah i've been i think in general i'm
really surprised over how positive most
of the reactions and the
comments on the videos are
when one considers the subject that i
talk about i would expect there to be a
lot more
uh
negative kinds of discussions and and
comments
and they are there of course but it's a
lot less denied than i would have
expected so i'm really glad that i have
such a
appreciative audience
joey asks if i'm a negative person i
wouldn't say so i think i'm pretty
i think i'm pretty positive i have a
i enjoy
life i think
i think i have a generally positive
outlook on on my life and and the world
uh
922 why was introduced your channel
yesterday where should i start from i
think it'd be good to start from some of
the more academically oriented
videos there's a video on essentialism
which talks about
the way that we approach religions from
a historical or from an academic
perspective of not decentralizing or
creating monoliths but but recognizing
the internal diversity
um
and
the fact that
religions evolve and change
over time so like essentially just
recognizing that
from
a neutral perspective right religions
are these incredibly diverse and
multifaceted things that can never
really be
um
as
a monolith or as anything
fixed in that way at least not to any
major degree and i think it's good to
have that
perspective before
starting to actually study the different
traditions that i talk about
that's that's the way i also structure
the release schedule for the podcast so
again for those of you who don't know i
just uh started
a let's talk religion podcast which is
just really
old episodes that i upload as
an audio form and the schedule for that
begins with those videos so
the video on essentialism and then a
video about
where what belief
is like why i think it's called why do
people believe
um and then
i go into the like what is
zoroastrianism or what is mendeism and
so on i think that's a good
way to approach studying this topic
justin's here
justin is a good friend and an amazing
guy
and i
look forward to
seeing his channel grow
as much
and to see him reach the same amount of
audience as
amazingly we now have two he really
deserves that and i look forward to
doing more collaborations with
justin over at esoteric too
sledgehammer is that a reference to the
peter gabriel song
because if so then i approve
we must say do i know arabic i think i
get this question every time i do a live
stream i do know i've studied arabic i
studied arabic for a year at university
and of course i've picked up on arabic
and studied arabic
while studying like islam and and so on
so i know a little arabic
um
i can read arabic like simple
arabic like simple text
ha essentially i don't know much in
terms of the dialects but i can read al
fusa and
especially if i have a dictionary with
me i can get through some of the more
more advanced texts too but in terms of
like speaking arabic
[Music]
not really i i'm not fluent
in that sense but
i know a little arabic
i get by
joey paisano again asks do you
experience joy
yeah
i experience joy
in uh
situations where it feels appropriate to
experience joy i don't think that
striving to always experience joy is a
good thing
that's not something i would want i
wouldn't want to feel joy all the time
probably because then it wouldn't be
special but also because i think
um as humans we are
more inclined to be like nervous and
anxious
um and so
like joy is a great feeling but the best
feeling to me
really is when you're like just content
which sounds dark maybe but just this
feeling of
just
nothing
i like those
kinds of days or moments
but joy is wonderful too when it is
again when it's appropriate
my native language is swedish
i was born in stockholm and i still live
in stockholm and i speak swedish
for the most part
except when i do these videos
i have now sort of laid the groundwork
for that because if we want to talk
about mulasadra we first need to talk
about ibn cena and we need to talk about
ibn arabi and we need to talk about
suhara vardy because molassadra
bases his whole philosophy on those
three philosophers and and then
his whole life his whole philosophy
sprouts from that and so if you don't
have a background knowledge in those
three then
you'll have a harder time understanding
molassadra now i've made three videos on
those figures and so
i'm ready to do mulasada video i might
want to redo the benzene video though
because that was one of the first ones i
did and i don't
like it's not like i disagree with
anything i say there but i can
definitely do
a better one like more in depth and
longer
but the malasada video is is approaching
definitely
i love these like really deep
philosophical questions why i asked why
do we suffer and why
why is there evil
[Music]
well i don't know really i can speak for
some of the
ideas of the the people i talk about
some of the philosophers and theologians
the constantly recurring figure on this
channel is ibn arabi and he essentially
adopts the idea of of the neoplatonist
people are plutanus
that
sees darkness essentially as the
the absence
of
did i say darkness he sees evil as the
absence of good
just like darkness is the absence of
light and so ibn alibi says well
everything is is god right in one sense
at least it's a reflection of god
everything that is evil everything that
is
negative right that's a result of
nothingness of non-being that which is
not god so the absence of god
is evil because the world
is in this
place of the bar
the isthmus the the the line in between
absolute being which is god and
non-being or nothingness and the world
stands at the very
line between these two worlds and so it
contains elements of both and so he
explains it that every
everything that is evil is a result of
nothingness and non-being
and everything
else
is from god or from light
in that sense i think that's a very
poetic way of looking at it i don't know
if i'm
ascribed to it myself but that's been a
recurring idea at least
of how to answer that question it's a
very difficult question one of the most
difficult questions
are you religious what do you mean by
religious then
if you mean
i'm not gonna answer this question i'm
gonna stay esoteric but i um
if you mean in a traditional sense of
being religious in the way that people
tend to refer to that term i think many
of you would consider me not religious
but it's it's also more complicated than
that so
maybe in some future
video or live stream i can i can
talk about that more in depth but
probably not there are some things i
just like don't like i want to keep to
myself
yes still it was
um this the esoteric thing wasn't a
conscious reference to the schweppe
podcast but
i've been listening a lot to that so
maybe it was like an
unconscious slip of the tongue
check out earl fontenell's podcast
called the secret history western
esotericism
amazing stuff
uh scalo is that how you want to me
pronounce your name have you experienced
any supernatural events in your life
not not as much as i would have wanted
to i would i would love to to have some
supernatural experiences
but i've been
[Music]
not really
i've had
experiences that some would
perhaps term
mystical perhaps or you know
my at least mildly uh
mystical experiences
but not like super not not anything an
extreme nothing i would call a
supernatural experience
but again i would love i would love to
that would be really interesting
three-way collab on maimonides and
mysticism i'm down i'm totally down
i still haven't read the
full translation of the guide for the
perplexed
but i really want to do a video about
the uh
about uh abraham
my moony
uh
my mother's son
who was a
was he a cabalist i know but he huge he
created this kind of syncretistic
movement of sufism and judaism which is
really exciting and i have that as like
a
video on my list that i really want to
do maybe we could like work something
out
in any case i'm definitely down to do a
collab like that
i've ever considered lsd
uh i mean i've consid i've considered it
it's it's been it's been a
i mean in the sense that like yeah it's
been something that's come up in
discussions
in my life but i never
i've never taken
lsd no
these again these are
some of these questions
i'm just going to keep
private
is religious literacy important in
today's world i think it's very
important because religions are
very
it's a hugely important factor in
society
in politics in in all kinds of in
culture like religion is all over the
place and it influences us in more ways
than we understand and so if
there was more religious literacy people
knew more about
different religions about
the topic of religion in general sense i
think that would only benefit us in many
different ways it's sad that so many
government institutions
uh are reluctant to hire experts on
religion at least here in sweden
um like the
department of defense essentially
has no interest in hiring people
like that they want to hire people who
are experts in military
stuff
which you'd think like do you do they
need that because that's kind of their
thing already but anyway
i i definitely think that we need more
religious studies institutions we need
more religious literacy and we need more
experts on religion to advise
politicians and political institutions
so yes
fidelio what impressed you impressed you
most about the quran
well the quran is really
this
the quran is a really beautiful
uh
book
if you read it in arabic right if you
listen to the quran recite it or even if
you just read it in the arabic it's
incredibly poetic right it is
i mean it isn't
muslims who say it's not poetry it's
something else but it's very poetic it
rhymes it has this meter and then this
this just a rhythm that's incredible um
so regardless of like the nature of the
quran where it comes from it's hard to
deny that it's a it's an amazing
document and it's an amazing
piece of writing
just in terms of its
of the beauty of its language
and it's in its poetry i think it's it's
really impressive
edward nogueta what are the funniest
assumptions people have made about you
whether you're religion or country of
residence
good question i was once accused of
being an agent for the pkk
um that was pretty funny
um
i don't know
people assume people on the internet
assume a lot of weird things
a lot of the time
that's the one thing that came to mind
just it's completely baseless
baseless claim
because i i don't know because i talked
about
kurdish religion or something i don't
know
kid trq do you think islam is very
influenced by judaism
yes
but
so that's a complex topic because
definitely of course islam develops out
of an abrahamic context including
judaism and early christianity and so on
but
muslims themselves will of course say
that well islam is the original
religion and judaism and christianity
are
have branched off from that original
religion so that's their perspective on
that they would say that no islam wasn't
influenced by judaism but two days and
muslims by
islam um putting that aside just looking
at islam as like this
assuming that islam arrives with the
prophet muhammad right the from a
historical critical perspective
then then i guess yes because
it it grows out of
a
abrahamic
religious tradition
danish raheem can you make a list of all
your books and share that list
that would be a really long list but i
think i might
do
i know that justin
sledge did a video about where he
basically like
gave a tour of his bookshelves i could
do something like that my bookshelf or
my book collection is not nearly as as
large as his
although he is at least a few years
older than me so i can
i can use that as an excuse but but
maybe i could do something like that
if you're interested i don't know if
that would be very interesting
thoughts on rumi i love rumi
i i love rumi i haven't made videos on
rumi because everyone loves room
everyone knows rumi
rumi is the most one of the most famous
poets in history
um
you know he's one of the most popular
poets in america of course many people
have read
you know questionable translations of
rumi
that often will take out
all of his
connections to islam essentially and so
there is a point
there is i think value in countering
that and then really showing an accurate
picture of rumi as as the muslim
thinker that he was the muslim poet that
he was
but even that there's a lot of content
about that too books and videos and so
on so but you know it's inevitable that
there will be a video about the rumi at
some point
rhubarb pie what's your favorite kind of
apple i like red apples
i don't know why
i'm not a big fan of apples generally i
like
i like the taste of apples but i don't
like eating actual apples
i think it's the like the the the
ickiness that's you know i i have some i
think have some kind of phobia of of
being
what's the word in english
like having
stuff on my hands that shouldn't be
there and like fruits and apples have a
lot of juice
and i don't like that but i love
things that taste like apple
justin has a very interesting question
what's your favorite religious headgear
wow
the pope has a pretty awesome
hat
hard to beat
um
i don't know
you're asking questions that are way too
good that i would need to to think about
um
sufi different what's interesting is
that different sufi orders have
often characteristic headgear so the
cloud that you order will have like a
like a certain headgear that they use
the medley order has this the very
famous very tall
tall headgear that they use
oh yeah coptic orthodox folks definitely
also good
i was adam speaking of the sufi headgear
was at a museum in istanbul the medley
museum if any of you been there
and there was this room that essentially
like had these different
head gears from different sufi orders
on display
which
is probably only interesting if you're
actually interested in sufism to begin
with but to me that was really
interesting
usmanza had thoughts on neoplatonism
i have complex thought about thoughts
about neoplatonism i
i i admire platinus hugely
and i love the any ads and i i think he
not only is he and his followers hugely
influential in so many ways but i just
think he's a brilliant
thinker a brilliant philosopher and like
such a fascinating personality it seems
like
so i'm i'm i'm a huge fan of the tinus
and the neoplatonists
that isn't to say that i
agree with everything they say or that i
buy everything but
yes
check out the the any ads by platinus if
you want to be
blown away
um
the estate of who have you done a video
on gershom sholem i haven't done a video
about him in particular but i've done
videos where he's come up and been a
significant part of
those videos i've i did a video
with dr justin sledge about a year ago
about abraham abulaffia
in which he is an important
part
that's probably one of like
you know i think all videos are
uh
good in various ways but my video on
on abu lafa
is one of those videos that i'm
especially proud of for some reason i
just
i watched it again a few weeks ago and i
just feel like
i did a good job on that one and having
it be a collaboration with justin is
also especially
great
a lot of questions guys
pluto is a planet what's your zodiac
sign i addressed this last week also i
don't i think it's i'm a capricorn i was
taught that i was a capricorn as a kid
i'm born on december 22nd
and so i
i was taught that i was a capricorn but
then once i checked a few years later i
was something else the one that's before
that
this like i just released a video in
astrology and i don't even know the
names of the science
uh
that's not the part i focused on during
my research
but needless to say aside from studying
that stuff
for these videos and as part of my
religious studies astrology has never
really been a part of my life or
anything that i've considered like that
rima's side how are you are you okay i'm
doing fine
i'm doing i'm doing well i have it
i really enjoy
everything
every everything that i do i have a job
day job that i that i feel is really
meaningful and that gives me a lot of
energy and
and the
you know feelings of love and
appreciation and
being able to do this channel
and reach all of you people and talk
about religion with all of you wonderful
people it's like i'm real i'm i'm really
happy about where i am
currently
and uh
yeah no other problems right now i don't
have
a tummy ache i don't know headache right
now i do have a dentist appointment on
thursday that i'm
not looking forward to but
i did a root canal treatment last week
which was not this is obviously not the
most wonderful experience
but uh you know you gotta stay stoic
about that stuff
like it sucks but it's okay that it
sucks that's my approach
sucker for pain asks if i believe in
barsa
so in islam
i assume this is what you mean we're in
islam the idea is that once you die you
go to um
you go to this place called the barasag
which is an intermediate or
middle
place where you
wait for the eventual day of judgment
where you'll be sent to you know heaven
or hell essentially
do i believe in it
i don't know
i
i've never cons so that's what's
interesting about studying all of these
topics is that of course a lot of the
time you're you're you're influenced by
what you read or you you know you're
inspired by what you read but a lot of
the time you just read these things and
you don't even consider asking yourself
if you believe in them
so that's one of those things but like i
know about it i've seen it various
a lot of times in different writings and
so on i've never actually asked myself
the question do i believe that this is
true so i don't know i can't really
answer that question
get kind of like purgatory yeah
not really but it's similar to purgatory
yes ulysses jonah yes root canal root
canal is like purgatory yeah basically i
i would agree
it's uh it's an hour of
that torture is too too strong but
joseph anders have you ever questioned
ever considered doing a video on
different atheistic movements throughout
history
yeah
yes i've
i've been getting a lot of suggestions
to do videos on the charvaka school of
indian philosophy for example which is
essentially an atheist school
[Music]
really fascinating stuff
[Music]
and and also modern day atheist movement
is or movements are
significant for for
religion or the the discussions about
religion in the world today so
yeah none of those videos are in
in the works right now and yes
um
i was just thinking about him when you
when you said atheist now now contrary
to popular belief
um
it seems pretty clear that to me that uh
al-maari wasn't an atheist
although he is often portrayed as one so
almari was an arabic poet a medieval
arabic poet who was really fascinating
controversial um
and people tend to say that he was he
was
he was atheist but
he he was critical of religious
institutions and and
you know
what many today call organized religion
but he seems to have been quite a pious
person himself uh judging from his
actual poetry he's
regardless
one of the probably the most fascinating
figures of that time at least in terms
of the
the poets the arabic poets he is one of
the the great ones
and yes i've definitely been been
considering doing videos on him or at
least one video
the the rock asks what sources i use for
my urban tymia video the sources are in
the description to the video
i always leave my sources as well
sometimes as just suggested readings if
you want to know more about the topic i
always leave that stuff in the
description to every videos if you want
to know what sources i used for that
video in particular
go check that description
i'm
not sure how long i'm going to be
streaming i think i'm going for an hour
now or something
yes about an hour i can do a little more
it's fun to talk to you guys
so
upcoming videos
are
have a few ones
the next one is probably going to be the
finishing part in the trilogy about
vedanta
uh specifically talking about madhva
or madhvacharya
and his school which is known as dwight
vedanta
so i already did the one on shankara and
one on ramanuja and vishishtadvaita and
this last one
is going to be about dwight davido which
is the dualist school of vedanta
that's at basically the complete
opposite spectrum or opposite side of
the spectrum from advaita which teaches
that all things are the brahman like the
self is identical with the brahman there
is only the brahman all all else is
maya
illusion
which is often misunderstood but
everything else is a superimposition
upon the brahman now mother and wife
is very different
he conceives of
the brahman as identical with vishnu as
a personal god with attributes and as
being different from the self and
different from the world and and yet he
and that school is also very significant
for the history of vedanta and the
tradition of vedanta so that's the next
video
then
i'm doing like i said earlier i'm doing
a video about sufi music which is one of
the
one of the most ambitious videos that
i've ever done
and i'm again i'm going to need a few
extra days or weeks to work on that one
the script is done but the editing is
probably going to take
a little longer so that's going to be
like a like a really comprehensive
overview of what sufi music is like both
in terms of practice like
like the the sama rituals of the sufis
as well as more theoretical
aspects of
how did these sufi writers and thinkers
view music from a you know psychological
metaphysical and ontological perspective
it's really really fascinating stuff and
i've been wanting to do that video for a
long time but it just felt so big and
ambitious that i
i put it off for a long time but finally
now i finished the script and that's one
of the next ones coming out
so those are some of the ones
the upcoming ones
uh the estate of ho ho ho ho uh will you
talk about music in islam in general i
kind of did that there is a there is a
series on the channel called music in
the islamic world
which is not necessarily about music in
islam but like
music in
the islamic world and what that means is
like the
made by muslims and in a context where
islam is the uh the ruling
the religion of the rulers
and the
paradigma
cultural
the religion
the majority religion essentially right
so
i have two a video series in two parts
about
music in the islamic world you can check
out and this next one will be
particularly about sufi the music of the
sufis
muhammad anik are you familiar with
rene going on and abdul hakim murad
winter
with both of them
i made very recently a video about the
shadowy
sufi order in which renegon is a
significant part
representing the sort of later western
or european developments of that order
and
um the perennial
philosophy the school of the perennial
philosophy
tim winter or abdul hakim
murad
hasn't shown up in a video except as a
source
because he has uh edited and written
great
stuff about islamic history and theology
um but he's a person that i admire a lot
i think he's a wonderful speaker and he
seems to be a
a great scholar
christos nikolao do you know any good
sources on yarshanism
not really because i've been wanting to
study that further and it's been hard
for me to find
good sources about that
like i do know
people who are connected to the
uh
to yoshanism
which is also known as the ali haq which
is a
religious movement
that originates in
i think and what is the iran right
also often associated with with kurdish
ethnicity
[Music]
it's on my list of to do things but i've
also had trouble finding like reliable
sources
so sorry i can't i can't give you
recommendations at this time but
as soon as i find them i'll
try to let you know
where
influenced by the various indian
philosophers i don't think so personally
i see very little reason to think that
he was directly influenced by indian
philosophies or hinduism or dwight david
or anything like that i think any
similarities to that comes either from
um just
i don't know either i think those
similarities come from a lot of the if
anything
in terms of an outside influence i think
it comes from an interpretation of
neoplatonist ideas but also i think
in my opinion i think there is there is
something to be said for
the a kind of common human experience
that even arabi and maestro eckhart and
shankara and these people
seem to experience things that are very
similar and
you could trace that to some kind of
intellectual you know
development and influence but i think
we shouldn't uh
discard the idea that there might be
some kind of common human
experience that can be reached and that
have been reached by these people
that
has a certain character that all these
people tend to express but in different
ways in terms of different religious
symbolism and languages now that isn't
to say necessarily that those
experiences are true or that you know
they
correspond to anything
in terms of an absolute reality or
anything that but that
these experiences can be had and that
they have certain characteristics that
are common even today you hear people
who you know
take lsd or mushrooms and they also
describe these things in very similar
ways that could be a result of that of
the fact that they have
already
you know heard these stories before and
then they project that onto their
experience but you know who knows but i
think
again one should discard the idea that
maybe there's just a common human
experience that all these people are
tapping into somehow
some maybe some psychological
or it could be a biological thing or
or something else i don't know
so
ergon again
asks me if
a lot of question marks
is it true
let's see is it true that originally
both hinduism and christianity believers
prayed three times every day
i think you're going to have to
[Music]
stop
spamming uh that question it seems to be
bothering some other people in the chat
but i'll gladly answer your question um
i've never
i don't know i don't i don't know
i haven't heard of anything like that
which maybe i should have
is andrew still in the
chat
maybe he can enlighten us about
early christian prayer customs
because i am not entirely sure
elmo player what's your favorite food
like i've never had favorites
whether it's you know food or it's
movies or it's music
i've never really had like
favorite things
like i've had things that i like more
than others but like i've never had i
shouldn't say never but for most of my
life i've never had like this is my
favorite movie or this is my favorite
band
or artist or anything um it depends on
what mood i'm in
[Music]
[Music]
are you enjoying this
silence we're being silent together it's
a
meditational practice of
i'm just kidding
i'm just trying to look for good
questions to answer
why do you think sweden is
is no religious or i think sweden isn't
religious
well i don't know if it's true that
sweden sweden or swedes aren't religious
um i think we're religious
this is a difficult term what does
religious even mean does that mean
adhering to a specific religious
institution what does that mean
you know in a sort of old-fashioned
uh
way you know
like eb tyler kind of definition of
religion as being
believing in supernatural things like
what does religious mean
uh
there's fascinating uh studies being
done by my professor david turfield as
well as many others that
focus on this in particular like the new
you know religiosity or
spirituality of swedish people as well
as other people in in the secularized
west
that definitely seemed to indicate that
people still
you know
you know because they believe in things
and they still um
place themselves within a kind of
world view that
reminds us of
what we call religions right so for
example nature a lot of swedes will say
that well nature is my religion or you
know they will go out into
nature and that's a kind of religious
practice a religious experience
there is this new thing called forest
bathing which originally comes from
japan but it's become really popular in
in europe and in the west
where it's a kind of therapy to just go
walking in the woods and
doing that as a kind of spiritual
practice
so i wouldn't say that
swedes are
not religious you know
take into consideration the many
problems with that term
i think it's just that people
the way that people are religious
is changing
as it always is
and so people in sweden don't for
example follow or adhere to the major
religious institutions organizations in
the same way that they used to that's
true that's true for a lot of places in
in in the secularized
you know in europe for example
but there's a lot more complexity to
that question than that
jay
risto are there any modern islamic
philosophers you think are worth
mentioning
i think so there are a number of
significant ones you know in my shadow
video i mentioned saying jose nasser
um
he i think is a very
significant
philosopher and thinker and figure in
the islamic world today
like we already mentioned
is very significant you have people like
you know hamsa yosef omid safi
these are people that i'm extra familiar
with because they're also involved in
academia for example as
scholars in a more broad sense
in terms of philosophers
what's his name there's a really
interesting guy
i think he's in malaysia he lives in
malaysia
i forget his name um
i can
post a comment something later or
something with a list of interesting
islamic
yes
that's who i was thinking about he's
really interesting too
airgun did mayans and aztecs believe in
one god
in many forms too well the aztecs they
have you know this pantheon of different
gods and you know the study of aztec and
mesoamerican religions are still in its
infancy in a lot of ways
but it seems that they had many gods who
represented you know natural phenomena
or things like that um but that there's
also this concept in aztec religion
what's known as the teot
which seems to be this kind of you know
almost pantheistic idea of the
um
oneness uh
you know a divinity that is
the the sort of uh
the one reality of all other things and
that the other gods are you know again
like manifestations of this one
concept
also kind of recurring theme in a lot of
religious traditions
the maya i'm not sure i think andrew
made videos about both the maya and
anaesthetic religions and he mentioned
in the maya episode
that
there might be a similar concept but
that there's still like debate over
whether
how accurate that is
i'm in no way an expert on mesoamerican
religion yet
um
but there's
some fascinating research that's being
done there
i've been going for almost so i'm going
to do like an hour and a half maybe i'll
do 10 10 more minutes or so and then
we'll call it a day
i've been working on
a setup in here for the videos on the
other channel the philip home channel
which is dedicated to music primarily
um
just having the camera like you're not
see you're not seeing the camera right
now but there's a camera here
you can you have the instruments in the
background
which is making
the filming of videos for that channel a
lot more
effortless
than
for this channel which allows me to be
more productive which i think is
wonderful
baroness elsa von freytag
loringhoven wow
amazing name is there a place
and time and history you would travel to
if you could
i would like there are interesting
things
i give such boring answers it's always
like well i would like to visit every
time and place but that's really like
that's true
like every time a place has something
interesting
except certain parts of europe during
the
plague perhaps maybe i wouldn't
i'd skip that i think but other than
that like i don't know alexandria in the
first couple of centuries
a.d
would be really interesting
uh you know obviously because
that's such a um a big part of what i do
i would love to
you know be in judea or on the time of
jesus or you know mecca and medina
during the time of prophet muhammad or
andalusia in the later middle ages
southern spain and so on
dj bano which do you prefer to read the
bible or quran
you know i'm not going to answer that
there's no there's no answer to that
that wouldn't be controversial um
i i like reading i like reading both
they're both fascinating documents
i i know arabic so i enjoy reading the
quran in arabic
even though i don't understand
everything but like i can appreciate
reading the quran in arabic and
appreciating the the rhythm and the
poetry of that but i also really enjoy
reading the bible
in in translation because of the
incredible history and and stories in
that book
or in those books
muhammad gonna goma are you familiar
with peter adamson yes i'm an avid
listener to the
history of philosophy without any gaps
it's just one of the best podcasts for
the history of philosophy
it's by
a professor i think called peter adamson
who's based in munich
and again
that's also highly i highly recommend
that
that podcast if you're interested in
knowing about the history of philosophy
and it really doesn't leave anything out
so a very common way to talk about the
history philosophy
has been to basically cover the
pre-socratics and then you know plato
and aristotle and
and the hellenistic schools the stoics
and so on and then from there like maybe
augustine like that might be like
[Music]
you could go that far and then you like
skip to the cart
which is like a thousand years
and so that's one of the points of that
podcast
which is also in the name is you know
the history philosophy without any gaps
then is
including and filling those gaps you
know the late antiquity the islamic
philosophers
and all of that which is really really
important for the history of philosophy
the middle ages
in the islamic world or in europe was
not some
you know
there were no dark ages in that sense of
you know a completely
intellectually dry
period in the middle ages in europe was
incredibly fruitful and there were a lot
of really original and new philosophies
and ideas and science being developed
and so i think it's important to
highlight that as well there's been a
lot of stuff about medieval thinkers and
philosophers on this channel partly for
the same reason that i think that they
are so often neglected and there's a
kind of general
you know misrepresentation of that
period in a lot of ways
so my back's starting to hurt so i
really we're going we're going for a few
more minutes
and then i'm gonna have to go rest
yes i'm
i might look young and i am 28 but
i'm kind of also 70 at the same time
have you heard of jason georgiana yes
but i can't recall
anything about who he is
remind me
because i've heard that name a lot of a
lot of the time
let's see here
junaid hi
did you see the painting the drawing i
made for you know
i don't think so where did you
did you send that to me somewhere
i would love to to take a look at it if
you
you can send it to me in an email
perhaps there's a my email address is on
the about page
on my channel
you can send it over if you want me to
look at it
so controversial
they weren't that controversial
i think in a lot of ways it was the
opposite
he
is one of the most
appreciated figures in islamic history
the way
you know in the way that he
took
sufism for example
and in works like the heirloom medin he
he makes
i wouldn't say a synthesis because that
overemphasizes the
the difference between sufism and you
know other
aspects of islam but he he created a
kind of
a way of looking at those things that
was a very appealing and to a more sort
of orthodox perspective and really made
a kind of
he became the mainstream for a number of
centuries essentially he's really only
become controversial lately because
of many misunderstandings about his
stance on
science and things like that like he
like that he ended the islamic golden
age which is
not true at all
you know you'd think that perhaps the
invasion of the mongols and the complete
destructions of all the great libraries
and cities of the islamic
civilization would have played a
perhaps more significant role than a
single scholar who didn't really say
anything that was all that controversial
at all but
anyway
toony stick was
attacked by kovitt19 i had coveted two
years ago
i can't believe i'm talking about kobed
i really i'm sick of talking about kobe
but i had it two years ago
um like right at the beginning
i lost all smell and taste for two
months and then had
this thing called
i don't remember the name but it's this
condition where everything tastes wrong
and everything tastes terrible and i had
that for like almost
on and off for like a year but now i'm
basically recovered
i think
you know there's a lot of questions and
i know the questions that you're asking
right now that i'm not answering are
questions that i've either already
answered previously on this stream so if
you want to know the answer to the
question you can just rewind and watch
uh
you know watch the earlier parts of the
stream or it's questions that i you know
want to keep
private or or questions that i don't
for other reasons don't don't wanna
don't wanna touch but i think i'm gonna
call it there we've been screen
streaming now for an hour and a half
as always i really enjoy talking to you
guys i hope my answers
weren't
too
incomprehensible
i certainly enjoyed talking to a lot of
you and i really enjoyed also seeing
some of my good friends in the chat like
justin and zevi and andrew
so i hope
you guys
have a great
rest of the day
and
that next week is
is is is as great as it can be
and that you
enjoyed my recent video also on
astrology
uh
no i can't i'm seeing a lot of
interesting questions i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna start answering questions i'll
have to do more live streams like this
perhaps next week or in connection to
releasing new videos
because i really enjoy talking to you
guys and i think that um
it's hard to like reply to all your
comments i try to respond to comments
the first few hours when a new video
comes out but then you know
it becomes really difficult to to and to
answer all those comments so this is a
really great way to engage with you guys
in a direct way and i really enjoy that
so
i'll i'll try to do it
more regularly
i can't promise anything but but i'll
try to do that so thank you all so much
for showing up again i hope you have a
great
rest of the day and yeah i'll i'll see
you in the next video thanks guys